[Music]
from east syracuse new york
ellie democrats line good morning
good morning yes mr knowles
i find you offensive your pompous way
the conservative party has done nothing
for america but divide us
and your book i probably would purchase
it to read
it i don't agree with anything you're
saying
check out history i am a history buff
and i read history and i was an
independent
all of my life until 2008
and i realized that i sided more with
some of the ideas of the democrats
you have conservative uh what about the
conservative movement in 1953
pushing religion right did you see the
the documentary the family
how they i i haven't seen that
documentary
well i think you should watch it because
it's very telling
and it tells you all about how a certain
set of republicans conservative
religious
which is in the constitution no laws
written
okay freedom means freedom to practice
your religion that way you want if you
want
freedom means if you are a lesbian
a gay lpgq whatever you call
that's your right right
uh okay well okay
hold on ellie will let her get respond
uh so uh all interesting points i
appreciate your willingness to buy and
read my book even if you
suspect that you won't agree with it um
to your point on religion you say that
the
the united states does not have any
religious underpinning and you should be
free to have whatever religion
you want let's not forget religion
factors into the declaration of
independence the declaration of
independence the entire american
revolution
is premised on the idea that there is a
god
our creator who endows us with certain
unalienable rights
so that idea which is a very christian
idea
is the basis the the philosophical basis
of the entire country
and if you were to posit a religious
view that would undermine that religious
basis
that would seem rather incoherent beyond
that
all governments all regimes have some
kind of religious basis this is
inevitable
at the ratification of the constitution
by the way this is very misunderstood
but the first amendment is ratified
there's no established church at the
national level
one of the reasons for that is that
there were many established churches at
the state level
and those those church establishments at
the state level persisted
for decades after the ratification of
the constitution
we have a state religion now the state
religion now is secular progressivism
we are now being told that it is
unacceptable in this
culture to question the idea that a man
can become a woman
well that is enshrining in our law
the the gnostic religious idea of
dualism that that our bodies and our
souls have nothing to do with one
another
and we really are our souls as we
discussed earlier in the show
to quote the great uh political
philosopher bob dylan
everybody's got to serve somebody
there's no question about that and then
you raise this point on freedom and
liberty which i think is so
important because it's misunderstood not
only on the left but it's misunderstood
on the right as well
there are two conceptions of liberty
here there is the modern call it liberal
idea of liberty
which is that liberty is the ability to
do whatever you want at any time and to
pursue your own desires
whatever they may be and this is an idea
that's held by the left but
but by a huge portion of the right as
well then there is the classical
idea of liberty the idea of liberty held
by our founding fathers
held by christianity held by the
pre-christian philosophers
and that idea is that liberty is not the
the ability to do whatever you want at
any time
but it is the freedom to do what you
ought to do
so just to bring that down to earth what
that means is
according to the modern idea of liberty
the heroin addict
is the most free person in the world
because no one's especially in states
where that drug is legal
because that person is not being told he
can't do something if he has the desire
to shoot up heroin
why gosh darn it he's going to do it and
as long as he's got a couple bucks in
his pocket
gosh could you imagine a person anymore
free of course we all know that guy is
not free at all
he's a slave he's a slave to his base
passions
and his appetites and his sin this is
why in the traditional understanding of
liberty
as christ says himself the man who sins
is a slave
to sin in the pre-christian
philosophical greek understanding of
liberty
the way that we become free is by
practicing the virtues by
cultivating our minds and disciplining
our wills this is the purpose of
liberal education the idea of liberal
education is that
we will come to make sense of our
liberty of our freedom
and be able to exercise it so that we
can tamp down those base passions that
we don't want to follow that compromise
our
our will and our intellect and be able
to pursue these higher things this is
what the founding fathers knew this is
why they wrote at great length
and i detailed this at great length in
my book speechless about the difference
between
liberty and licentiousness it in the
modern
era in the modern age today the left and
the right both seem to think that
liberty and licentiousness
are the same thing what our founding
fathers knew and what
wise people throughout history have
known is that liberty and licentiousness
are actually polar opposites
that licentiousness totally undermines
liberty
it's uh it's what you're seeing around
us right now and it reminds us of john
adams's
warning that our constitution our
republic is built for
moral and religious people and it's
unfit to the governance of any other
sort of people
this is not just some sunday school
scolding that he's giving us he's just
he's telling us a fact
about liberty if we can't tamp down our
base passions we are not going to be
able to govern ourselves
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video